you're so opposite because I've only
been in one fight it in my life it was
in ninth grade playing basketball it was
against a dude named Mitama like I'll
never fit em is Mitama Drake and I threw
one punch and I hit him right in the
face and he looks at me and goes what's
up and I was like you get away with it
oh yeah we start playing bass thank God
like that was it like literally I hit
him as hard as I could I could take a
shot oh and he was just like what's up I
was like nothin nothin is up so that's
the only didn't hit you back no wow
no cuz I then I started you know oh you
okay it's your ball yeah man yeah did
not try to get you back I mean I I was
there was a club in Houston named power
tools that I used to the gay bar no it
was yeah it sounds like one Shelly's
hardcore game in Houston the gay bar was
called Rich's at the time but I worked
at power tools and I was a bouncer so
that's when I was like 250 pounds you
know you were a lot bigger when I met
you oh yeah because I played college
football for Arkansas so I played
outside linebacker so I'll just stop
lifting weights or do you still a little
bit no I'm all cardio now because yeah
you know like trainers any trainer I
work with since I got a big frame we're
like well put some set no I want to stay
lean right you know but that's good for
old age to me you know back problem I
got 44 years old now yeah crazy dude to
ramp flies 51c or 55 zero do it it is so
scary when you read stories about people
just dropping dead you like a rat age
Luke Perry that's what I'm saying mainly
my age well they said what what is the
danger zone zone is like 45 to 55 with
heart failure it's like creighton ah
man did I beat my body up I'm running
that bitch until the fucking wheels fall
off I'm always getting stem cells shots
and I'm out fucking and running hills
and lifting weight I still love heavy
weights I'm retarded
yeah why don't you do that word I said
it again trying to get that rid of that
word out of my vocabulary it just comes
out sometimes why
why are you still lifting weights like
heavy like that like what is it do for
you well it does a bunch of things first
of all if you want to train jiu-jitsu
it's okay very good to be strong yeah it
makes a big difference first of all for
defense especially for defense
you know like for offense for sure - but
really you want to be able to defend
you're like defending is you have to be
strong but also you just like being
bigger it helps yeah I like it yeah I
like being able to pick up things I like
the physical ability of being strong I
like being in shape to being able to run
for long distances I like knowing that I
can go rounds on the bag like I'll do
five hard rounds on the side you can run
at my knees a messed up I can't like get
on a treadmill and run I can do like
I've done the stem into me and it's
helped out a lot but I'm still that dude
that's on I'm like on this super
fortunate I'm super passionate about my
knee injuries I've had knee injuries but
my meniscus I only had one meniscus
scope on my left knee and wasn't
terrible like I was back to full 100%
function after that and my right knee it
didn't I have a little baby tear that I
got some stem cells shot into but I had
both of them reconstructed there is
yells were replaced but no problems they
work they work great yeah I see I just
need to I listen to you and it's like
you always taking something and I'm like
oh I got to find out what that is and
now I just want to get in better shape
I'm in shape but I it's when you get
older it's just like tough it's just
it's just so he is writing it down like
you have to do it like do you keep a
daily sketch it you have to do no I just
wake up and go I I do have I wake up I
work out like a cardio workout and then
I do infrared sauna which has changed my
life so you do life right every morning
i infrared sauna housing it's the best
you sweat all that shit out you're like
you feel great your skin glistens like I
think it's actually like changed the
game for me I have more energy now
everything's better it's so good for
your body they did a study that showed a
40% decrease in mortality mortality
amongst all causes heart attack stroke
cancer 40% decrease with people that
were doing the song of four times well I
will tell you this because the whole
thing is everybody wants to feel young
and when you were young the thing you
did most was sweat and I feel like when
I sweat it
it's a it feels I don't know I just feel
good sweating because it reminds me when
I played sports it reminds me even
though I'm not doing on the you know I
sweat a little on the treadmill but when
I do that infrared sign it makes me feel
great ma I think is there's a bunch of
shit going on with this - yeah for sure
like it's good to feel good like your
sweater but there's heat shock proteins
your body actually produces
anti-inflammatory properties it's really
good for you it's really good for joint
aches and all kinds like this I used to
think of the Sun as being nonsense like
what do you want fucking what are you
doing they're just getting hot yeah
score capital look at what kind of a
sauna do you do though I do a regular
sauna
okay say superhot regular sauna telling
you you need to try the infrared yeah
you can yeah I mean but look it's all
just about getting your body huh yeah
like it's good to try to infrared I'm
sure I'm sure it works great but this
study the 40% decrease in mortality that
was with a regular stone so okay yeah
yeah that's why I got a regular sauna
cuz dr. Rhonda Patrick told me they'll
come the studies that have been done
they've all been done with a regular
sauna and she said there might be some
benefit of four infrared sauna but I
don't know what's published what does it
see if there's a benefit see if this
they could say what's the benefit to
infrared something cook in my organs I
don't even know it no I don't think so
no I mean it's great for just feel
amazing after that's supposedly what
happens right it gets deeper in your
tissues yeah it's yeah I remember us
texting back and forth I was like you
got it like if you do the infrared sauna
for like a week it's a game-changer
it's honest too so I don't know I would
like you to try regular sauna - how hot
does it infrared get like a hundred and
forty 140 that's fine heating the air
though - it's a difference yeah it
doesn't like you walk in and it feels it
doesn't feel like it's that but that's
your microwave shit probably burning up
all my organs right now but I love it I
like living in and feeling that super
heat you going there Euler oh it feels
so good